is that your answer your policies
are working at the border that is a
completeness characterization of our
policies working at the border what i
have said
what i have said before and i repeat
answer my question
are your policies working at the border
mr secretary yes
or no are they working we have a plan
we are executing the plan the plan takes
time to execute
what makes the plan more challenging
is number one covid hovid was at its
height a year ago mr secretary
with all due respect we saw none of
these numbers a year ago
this crisis has occurred under your
tenure this is a crisis that you have
engineered with your
policies that was senator josh hawley
making an important point to homeland
security secretary alejandro mayorkas
this is engineered by the democrats what
they're doing at the border is
purposeful
now look no further than what we learned
from axios tonight
50 000 illegal immigrants have been
released into the country
without a court date and told to report
to an ice office instead
well just 13 percent have showed up so
far senator hawley
joins me now senator now they won't come
out and say it but
you can't convince me that this isn't
what
the democrats want a massive influx of
humanity into the united states
laura it's exactly what they want and i
think one of the reasons that secretary
marcus wouldn't say that they
their plans weren't working he just
wouldn't answer that question is because
their plan
is an open border their plan is amnesty
and their plan is to dismantle ice
and by the way they're doing every
single one of those things and they're
trying to call it different
things they're trying to label it in
different ways they're trying to hide it
but what you look at
when you look at what's happening you
see a border that is open
you see effective amnesty for criminals
and then you see them
taking away isis enforcement capability
this is their plan and they're executing
executing on it and boy is it bad for
this country
now iowa governor kim reynolds today
suggested that
some of these aliens are partially to
blame for rising covet 19 cases saying
part of the problem is the southern
border is open we've got 88 countries
that are coming across the border
they don't have vaccines so none of them
are vaccinated and they're getting
dispersed throughout the country
well for that senator hawley governor
reynolds was attacked
by joe henry state political director
for latin american citizens group and
said that reynolds comments amounted to
hate mongering so senator this really
isn't about covent
really i mean it's not about coven this
is about
uh protecting the sensitivities of
illegals
against apparently name-calling uh what
they were called for
you know decades in the u.s code aliens
you know it's amazing too at a time when
we've got the cdc today reversing their
guidance on masks and now saying that
even vaccinated people
have to wear masks indoors i mean which
is insane in its own way laura but at
the same time to allow
a flood of illegal immigrants across the
border
it's not as if we're testing people when
they come across they're allowed into
the country allowed into the interior of
the country
and the bite administration just doesn't
care i mean on the one hand they say oh
it's a public health crisis on the other
hand they're doing nothing at the border
to try to stem it so
this is part of their plan lord i mean
the truth is they want an open border
and that's what they're getting
well so their plan is working i think
that's your point and that that was a
phenomenal uh
series of questions but their plan is
working
because they want to bring in as they
already have this year
double the size of the city of cleveland
a million people so far have been
apprehended at the border 1 million
there's some good news senator i got to
get to this this fresh polling from the
nrcc saying 7 out of 10 voters in
battleground districts
express high levels of concern about
rising prices
and the higher cost of living further
voters in these battleground districts
trust republicans over democrats in
congress
to deal with crime and public safety
independents and hispanics senator
also disapproving of biden's handling of
the border crisis
by a staggering 23 percentage points
this is terrible news for the democrats
and maybe there's a silver lining here
at least
for next year's midterm senator your
thoughts
well it's just reality and what you see
is you see joe biden totally out of
touch with reality and the american
people don't want an open border
the american people don't want this
crime wave that he is allowing to crash
all over the country the american people
don't want runaway inflation yet he is
allowing and pushing forward
all of these things and when it comes to
the border laura you know you look at
the chaos there you look at the violence
you look at the drugs that are coming
across i mean it's insane
and the american people don't want it
and i think what they're they're trying
to send joe biden a message he's not
listening
senator finally today you filed i know
an amicus brief at the supreme court
and it states in part this status quo is
untenable
roe and casey should be overruled the
question of abortion legislation should
be returned to the states
senator given um some wobbly members of
the supreme court they're
very averse to rocking the boat
especially with this court commission
bubbling bubbling over with potential
court packing in the offing
do you really think that this court is
going to want to overturn roe versus
wade at this point
well i sure hope that they will i mean
that's a decision that i think is a
historically unjust
decision laura one of the worst
decisions in american history 62
million innocent unborn babies have lost
their lives
since row and listen the state of
mississippi who's the lead
plaintiff in this case petitioner has
asked the court to overturn roe
that was the right thing to do to ask
them and i'm proud to to ask for the
same and joined by senator lee senator
cruz
who are asking the court to do the same
so we'll see i'm hopeful
that the court will see that they they
committed a historic injustice when they
just
invented this constitutional right to an
abortion all these years ago and now
it's time to put it right
senator great to see you tonight thank
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else